romans they existed then some stuff
happened and now they don't
and the people who live in rome's former
heartlands are now called italians but
when did this change occur
when did the romans become italians now
the answer to this question is dependent
on what your definition of roman is
is it a person living in the roman
empire people identifying themselves as
roman
speaking latin or upholding the ideals
of the roman empire
if it's living in the roman empire then
for the people in what's now italy it
was roughly 476 that it all came to an
end
sort of you see despite them being a
part of the brand new kingdom of italy
the first one that is
they still had a roman senate in fact
they still had the roman senate would
have spoken latin and were officially a
client state of what was left of the
roman empire in the east
many who lived there still considered
themselves to be romans and odawasa
italy's new ruler referred to himself as
being king of both romans and goths
odd oasis successors mostly used the
same terminology but it wasn't long
until emperor justinian and his trusty
general belisarius came knocking and
reconquered italy on behalf of
constantinople
they held onto it all for about seven
minutes before the lombards turned up
and conquered some and then a lot of the
territory of italy
importantly the eastern roman empire
still held on to some lands there which
started the long-running political
divisions of the italian peninsula
however in the territories ruled by the
lombards the institutions of the roman
empire notably the senate were abolished
and so began some good old-fashioned
absolute feudal monarchy
that said the idolization of rome
persisted and roman law remained
dominant
after this the process of change was a
slow one the lombards maintained control
over much of italy despite making up
about five percent of its population for
over two centuries
and the kings there soon stopped
referring to their subjects as romans
but as lombards
whilst at first both roman and germanic
law was used over time germanic law
became the dominant one
whereas in the parts ruled by byzantium
greek became the language of government
but the people there were still
considered to be romans
that said there were cultural
differences now between the byzantine
romans and their subjects living in
italy
when religious fervor led to the
empire-wide iconoclasm the destruction
of images on religious grounds the
romans living in italy didn't bother
when the franks turned up in the eighth
century and conquered most of the
peninsula the people living there were
not considered to be romans by most
outsiders
latin was still the primary language of
the region and over the next four
centuries it slowly morphed into
medieval italian
so with rome done and its identity a
thing of the past when did the people in
italy become italians
well regional identities separated along
political lines
venetians florentines neapolitans and of
course romans
but in the sense of living in and around
the city of rome not being literal
citizens of the roman empire
it wasn't until the renaissance that the
idea of the people who lived in italy
all being italians in a much deeper
sense started to pop
up this process was a very slow one but
it took off after the napoleonic wars
this was when the people living in the
italian peninsula got fed up of all
these foreign powers ruling over them
and fighting their wars there and as
such writers and activists started to
define what an italian was and how to
build them a nation
yet even after italy was born many of
the people who lived there still saw
themselves identify first and foremost
by the region of their birth
but for most of the people living in the
italian peninsula they were italians no
longer romans proper but the successes
and bearers of their legacy
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly moneymaker marvin
cassow rob waterhouse moe james
castaneda aaron the whites jordan
longley gustav swan jerry landon marcus
asner rasheed ali miss izzette copper
tone spinning three plates maggie
paxkowski winston cayward matthew
shipley spencer lightfoot anthony
beckett lexi schwinn
robert wedsell corso wolf sky chappelle
and charles the first